a lot of weather of news this morning
the first hurricane to hit Florida in 11
years is blasting through the Panhandle
after being downgraded to a tropical
storm hermine packed a powerful storm
surge and heavy rain causing significant
damage to a broad area of the northeast
Gulf Coast it made landfall overnight
with top winds of 80 miles an hour the
storm is now headed toward the Atlantic
coast our correspondents are all over
the impacted areas mark Strassmann
begins our coverage in Tybee Island
Georgia where the eye of the storm is
headed mark good morning to you good
morning here on the Georgia South
Carolina border the residents here are
hunkered down for the back half of the
storm wind gusts of up to 65 miles an
hour but the real story today is going
to be rain forecasted for 4 to 8 inches
here at possibly 10 inches by tomorrow
storm surge here maybe 10 feet when high
tide hits in a couple of hours potential
for both coastal and inland flooding all
the way up to the state of Maryland here
at Tybee each they brought in 20 tons of
sand so residents can sandbag their
businesses and residents and lifeguards
are flying a double red flag here which
means these beaches are closed at least
till tomorrow morning Labor Day weekend
at the beach is off to a rough start
d'marco all right thanks to mark
Strassmann in Tybee Island Georgia